this is tamar hussein reading for
reviewer randolph ramsay my kids had a
litany of questions during our first
game of mario party superstars where my
12 year old son asked was monty mole his
favorite character from the last game
why are there no mini games where you
have to waggle the controllers around my
seven-year-old door asked why are there
so few characters to choose from anyway
and why does everyone have the same dice
block my kids have had a lot of
experience with super mario party the
previous game in the series which was
released on the nintendo switch in 2018
so these comparisons were inevitable the
newest entry mario party superstars is a
deliberate embrace of the mario party
series early days before motion control
gimmicks and twists on its classic game
mode became the norm this is a game that
delivers on the core mario party
experience and is high on nostalgia but
my kids questions highlighted the
trade-off that comes with their approach
in embracing the old superstar loses a
lot of tweaks and additions that have
livened up recent merrier party games
making superstars as much of a step back
as it is a throwback
[Music]
that step back doesn't necessarily mean
mario party superstars is a bad game but
it does feel like a dated one if you've
ever played a mario party game before
then superstars will feel instantly
familiar thanks to its stripped back
focus on the series of staples dynamic
shifting boards a huge selection of fun
mini games and more than a hint of tear
your hair out randomness that gives
almost every game and anything can
happen feel
[Music]
depending on your age that familiarity
may also extend to superstars a
selection of boards and mini-games many
of which were taken from the very start
of the mario party franchise back in the
nintendo 64 and gamecube days i'm
certainly old enough to remember the
very first mario party back in the late
90s so it was fun to get that hit of
nostalgia dopamine when playing on
classic boards like peach's birthday
cake and yoshi's tropical island
nostalgia can only take you so far
though so it's good that superstar's
boards all taken from the first three
mario party games still feel fresh and
engaging to play each of the boards here
feature their own unique twists and
turns that force you to think on the fly
as conditions change yes it's still hard
to shake the rage that comes when
seemingly random in-game events conspire
to thwart carefully laid plans but mario
party superstars like most mario party
games shines in those occasional moments
when your multi-turn strategy actually
does bear through you have to for
example pay close attention to the day
night cycle in horrorland to make sure
the path you need will open by the time
you reach it is one of your opponents
one move away from toadette and
therefore an all-pressure star on
yoshi's tropical island then now is the
time to use that custom dice block to
land exactly on the event space that
switches told it and bowser's locations
during one tense game i used a triple
dice block to make sure i could hit told
that space to grab a star before
continuing on to a boo space where i
paid the annoying ghost to steal a star
from an opponent two stars in one turn
superstar's mini games are similarly
cripped from mario party games of old
and if you're feeling full retro there
are even options at the start of each
game to only play mini-games selected
from the n64 or gamecube eras there are
a hundred games here and among them is a
great selection of classics including
the always hectic bumper balls book
squirm hexagon heat and one of my
personal favorites the bowser contorting
facelift superstars even brings back
some controversial minigames that
require rotating your controllers and
log sticks like tug of war which caused
many a blister and even lawsuits back
with the original mario party but now
are accompanied by a special warning as
is typically the case with such an
expansive list not every one of these
selections is a winner i'm not a fan of
many games like crazy cutters and trace
race that require precise movements such
as tracing over a line for example but
they are ones my son gravitates to
because he's young and has much better
eyesight and motor skills than i do all
of the minigames in supercells are
controlled solely by using buttons and a
joystick which means none of the
joy-con's motion capabilities are
utilized this approach has its obvious
benefits unlike super mario party which
could only be played using single joy
cons any switch controller can be used
in superstar and the game can also be
played completely in handheld mode the
move away from joy con reliance also
importantly means mario party superstars
is the first new mario party game
released for the switch that can be
played on all flavors of the handheld
including the switch light making the
game available to all types of switch
owners is a positive but removing motion
control games does paradoxically limit
the types of players that can enjoy
mario party superstars take my daughter
as an example motion control mini games
were her favorite as the intuitive
controls allowed her to keep pace with
her brother and grown-ups during a game
session she was much more disinclined to
play superstars because of this and i
can imagine many other little ones and
many other casual players will feel the
same way the lack of motion controls
just adds to the being there played that
feeling that permeates the mario party
superstars experience this game for
better or for worse is the mario party
of old which is fine for gen z is like
me looking to scratch a nostalgia itch
but others more used to how mario party
has evolved in recent iterations even in
his own gradual ways will be a little
disappointed i miss for example some of
super mario party's additions such as
unique dice blocks that actually add a
layer of strategy to the character you
choose as well as the sound stage mode
that was frantic fun to play with the
kids there's nothing wrong with classic
mario party but i've played that game
before that's not to say that despite
the heavy emphasis on the past that
mario party superstar doesn't have any
concessions to the new there are several
welcome quality of life additions such
as being able to exit a game midway
through and resume it later online
player integration in all modes and the
ability to add extra turns at the end of
a particularly close game as well as an
excellent mini game only mode that
groups the 100 games into buckets such
as sports action team based and more
mario party superstar certainly provides
the highs that the series is capable of
but unless you're restricted to playing
on the switch light or itching to play
with a pro controller there's a better
version of this game available for you
and your loved ones to play in super
mario party
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
winner